so um so bridgette said i'm dilara and
uh i'm a former oncologic research
fellow
and i'll be taking you through the
process of conducting research on astro
science using
genome uh using omics uh through the t
bioinfo platform
um
first i will tackle some key points in
research like how to come up with a
hypothesis where and how to find good
data and how to convince an audience
that your research is relevant and
important
then i will take you through my research
and show which data and graphs are best
to present and which ones i chose
and we will even practice one a pipeline
practically
so the hypothesis could be the start of
your research or vice versa for me the
purp and for the purposes of my research
i decided to start
uh here so while i was reading articles
to find a topic that intrigued me i came
upon the gut brain axis and since my
preferred field was astrobiology i
decided to study how the gut microbiome
affects the nervous system of astronauts
my hypothesis was based on
how high led linear energy transfer
ionizing radiation
affected the nervous system of
astronauts
my hypothesis was based on this type of
radiation for several reasons like the
fact that it causes chemical reactions
i surmise that this type of radiation
would have
adverse effects on the human body and
the gut microbiome
now on to finding a good data set
uh you can actually search for articles
that are published in high impact factor
in well-known uh arctic uh well-known
journals because they are um very well
peer reviewed
very rigorously peer reviewed and you
should also try to pick ones with high
sample numbers
since you can get better results in
machine learning
techniques with a
huge numbers of samples
as you can see mine was categorized
based on the radiation and time and i
had 80 samples
and of course you can search ncbi and
some other platforms like jgi for um
microbiome data and as for the pipeline
it is important to
choose an appropriate pre-processing and
processing method since you have a lot
of data that you have to filter through
when you have
huge amounts of data
and you can do this using the tbi info
server so if you would like we can try a
hands-on example and then i can take you
through which graphs i chose from those
results
um and then
we can
continue like that so i guess the link
is already in the
chat so if you can quickly go there
and you will come to this page where
there are numerous
different areas of analysis
and from my
type of data i chose amplicon16s18s
because of
the type of data that was in the article
was 16 as rrna data
so here you can see a demo
and if you are following with me
we can here you can see as well
pre-processing for this demo there isn't
pre-processing but for my art for my
data there was
which helps remove
primers etc
and here we are trying
all of them i hope everyone can see
because i can't see the chat right now
so if you have any problems please let
me know
and what is great is the the dota 2
pipeline here and the final seek
pipeline you can run them both together
at the same time
and then
here you can see
i will pick this one the other two and
final c plots pdf
and if you go there
here
you can see the abundance plot here
a heat map showing the differences in
the abundances
a phylogenetic tree showing both the
abundances as well here the shannon
index that i will be explaining in
detail
and here we have uh nmds plots
um so you can go through those uh in
your free time if you would like and now
i'll go back to
the
to my data specifically
and show you
uh so basically
my ngs data which is the 16s rn rrna
data was collected from tc samples of
mice exposed to different types of two
four different doses of radiation and
these samples were collected at 10 days
and 30 days post radiation
so from these results i decided to pick
the nmds plot which is a non-metric
multi-dimensional analysis plug which is
a data reduction technique which means
that you can
input high amount of data and it will
the machine learning
algorithm will filter through this data
and it will only give you the points
which have a great variance and have a
great effect on the data
so you can see here um
at the differences between the groups
and at 10 days post radiation that group
is slightly more separated than the
others
so the next output that i chose was
the shannon index
since it gives us a general idea about
the richness and evenness of bacteria in
the samples it is a great plot because
it summarizes everything the alpha
diversity the better diversity of the
microbiome and here you can see that for
lower doses of radiation like 0.1 and
0.25 gy the diversity decreases more
compared to the control group
so
next i decided to use the phylogenetic
tree and
this one has a bonus because we can see
the abundances based on the categories
as well as you can see the otus that
have a great effect as here the
algorithm filtered those out for us
so otu three four and five are the ones
that i'll be focusing on in the next
step
and here you can also see that for
0.1 gy at 10 days it has the greatest
decrease in abundance compared to zero
gy
to corroborate the results uh i also
conducted a t-test and an f-test on
excel
and uh using the t-bind for server again
in the utility section you can even
generate heat maps
and that's why it's really great using
this platform because i didn't know
coding uh very well and
i can't say i'm very efficient at it
yet so
you don't need to know these things you
can directly start
generating graphs without knowing how to
code using this platform
so i generated this heat map and as you
can see all the graphs that i use uh are
the graphs that summarize large sums of
data
which is helpful when explaining a new
concept to an audience
here you can see the difference in
abundances for otu three four five and
eight
uh they are significantly decreased
between point one and zero gui
i then decided to search the keg
database
for these four otus
um because i didn't have names exactly
so and they corresponded to
lactobacillus and by for the bacterium
genus and i found out that these have
protein coding genes in the gaba pathway
gaba is gamma aminobutyric acid and it
is a chief neurotransmitter in the in
the central nervous system and causes
depression and anxiety when in low doses
so we can conclude that lower doses of
radiation especially 0.1 gui collected
at 10 days post radiation
the abundances of these four types of
bacteria decrease the most and since
they have they produce gaba we can say
that it has a correlation to the
depression anxiety that astronauts
suffer during long-term flights
and that my initial hypothesis about the
gut brain axis is also correct of course
further research is required but this is
a good precursor study and probiotics
can help alleviate some of the symptoms
of these astronauts
so what did i learn personally
during this project submission and while
conducting this research
first of all um
i learned how to sort through good data
and find a good quality articles
and and you become more efficient at
creating a narrative so that your
readers and listeners can understand
your research the more you write the
better you get at it and especially
referring to your mentors during this
stage is great because they will
help you throughout the process and you
can
efficiently estimate the quality of the
data as well
and then you will come out also knowing
which graphs are best to recapitulate
your data and how to summarize your
research
and overall
if you are rigorous during this
stage
you can also learn how to conduct
scientific data in an excellent manner
so here are my references and if you
have any questions feel free to ask me
you can inquire anytime
and thank you for listening